hi cosmic warriors it's me ELISA I'm an
astrologer and today we are going to be
looking at the charts of Ariana Grande
and her boo
Pete Davidson these charts are very very
interesting and I'm so excited to tell
you guys what I see a natal chart is a
snapshot of the sky at your exact moment
of birth so it really is everything you
could ever want to know about somebody
it is your cosmic fingerprint so
ultimately when we're looking at
compatibility we want there to be an
easy alignment between the two different
natal charts so that both people are on
the same page so we have Ariana who is a
cancer so happy birthday Ariana it just
passed she is a moon goddess and what
that means is that her moods are
constantly changing so she needs to be
with somebody who can keep up with her
very very shifting and constantly
switching up if she's in a good mood or
a bad mood and to better to do that than
a Scorpio which is another water sign
and what is more big-dick energy than a
Scorpio instant compatibility between
these two right water and water is great
together
I mean I'm turned on like it's pretty
sexy another interesting thing that I
need to point out when it comes to
Ariana Grande is that she has a ton of
cardinal energy so she is a Capricorn
rising she is a cancer Sun and then her
moon is in Libra so all of these
energies are working together and Pete
Davidson is fitting very neatly into her
chart really completing it in a way and
activating all of these things
simultaneously making her feel sexy and
good about herself the Sun making her
feel professionally in the spotlight
Capricorn and then also giving her the
partnership that her moon in her own
chart wants her Uranus not Uranus Uranus
is right on her ascendant this shakes
[ __ ] up she actually loves to [ __ ] with
us
she loves to shake things up and go from
good girl image - a bad girl image - a
ponytail - a knot ponytail that is her
favorite thing to do what is keeping
people on their toes more than this
completely unexpected relationship that
to the average person makes absolutely
no sense at all however within her chart
its strategic it's smart and it's sexy
and you know that they're having amazing
sex right that is that BDE
what I see going on with them is to be
honest a lot of strategy Arianna and
Pete Davidson absolutely know what
they're doing there is a big picture
scheme behind this and I'm not saying
that it's nefarious and I don't think
that they're being Shady
but I think that they really respect
each other professionally and I think
that they're recognizing that what one
person can offer the other is going to
be really important for their public
image for their careers and all of this
[ __ ] of them hiding from the
paparazzi give me a [ __ ] break you
know that all they want to do is be
spotted they understand what it means to
be a celebrity what it means to have
people following you what they're doing
in their private world is they're having
these interesting conversations about
how can we shift our image right and
work together in order to create
something really interesting and dynamic
I literally think that they might go
into comedy together I actually think
that they might do a sketch show they
might do a little YouTube thing and it
would be super funny and cute because
ultimately they're inspiring each other
creatively they're igniting each other's
sense of humor their spirits their
laughter they like to be together I hope
that they last I think that this is a
really nice partnership and I think that
it's a really good and interesting and
unique bond right they have something
special that we can't fully understand
but on the inside everybody absolutely
gets thank you so much for joining me I
hope that you learned a lot about our
friends Arianna and Pete I hope you
learned a lot about yourself my name is
ELISA I'm the author of the mixology of
astrology and I will see you next time
[Music]